نتحمل بعضنا احنا في شده احنا في شده لازم
نتحمل
[موسيقى]
بعضنا احنا يا عم عاملين النظام هذا عشان
نساعد الناس لانه الناس لجوا من غزه الى
الجنوب ولا رغيف ياكله ولا في طحين ولا في
خشب ولا في ل الخشب قاعدين بنشتريه
والطحين قاعدين بدبر للناس ونمشي امور
الناس الله يك بعونهم اقول لكم ما بدناش
مصاري كمان من الناس ببلاش مش لوجه
الله المشكله عننا في الخشب وش شرياه
وبنفع حق مساري بس عشان نساعد الناس
الموجوده زي ما انت شايف الناس وض حصيب
الناس اجت الهدوم اللي عليها والناس يعلم
الله كيف فضحها واحنا بنمشي مع الناس
ونتحمل الناس تمام عشان بس عشان ربنا يفك
الكربه اللي احنا فيها بس مش اكتر مع ان
الخشب وضوع صعب عنا يعني اول لك ما فيش
خشب اصلا فيش
من الشوارع وبندفع مصاري
حقه افرج كيف الخين نساعد الناس يا
عمي